technology is very very important
saddleback church every time the word of
God has been put into new new technology
there has been a spiritual awakening in
history and we've always been fast
forward on this because Billy Graham was
a great influence on me Billy Graham was
one of the first guys to use movies to
use a simulcast to use things like that
Saddleback was I think the first church
to ever use a fax machine to get the
message out and in the early 80s I think
when they're like 13 faxes in the entire
world I started a weekly inspirational
devotional and I would write it for
business leaders and we would fax it out
to business leaders who wanted it we
call it the facts of life and then these
business leaders would fax it to their
downlink and they would fax it to their
factory workers and on and we had that
fax machine was going 24 hours a day in
the early days of facts when the
internet came on Saddleback was the
first church on the Internet it was in
1992 and we've always been that was
before there was a internet next
Netscape or Internet Explorer we were
using google I mean a gopher and mosaic
and ftp we were the first church on the
internet and I decided instead of going
on television and put my sermons on TV
that I would put them on the internet
and allow other pastors and priests and
ministers to download them around the
world and then I could help them instead
of building a giant kingdom ministry
myself to encourage other people so I
don't copyright anything I do and
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
pastors around the world literally on a
daily basis download my sermons one
example that I got to tell you this one
is in our network of churches we have
now over 450,000 close to 500,000
churches around the world in the purpose
of a network and what that means is I
know more about a lot of disasters
before other people do because I got
people on the ground before it gets
announced for instance when the tsunami
hit in Southeast Asia a couple years ago
I was up about four o'clock in the
morning on my computers after Christmas
and all sudden email comes in from a
friend of mine who leads the largest
church in sri lanka in colombo sri lanka
5,000 member church a purpose-driven
church and he said rick as i'm typing
this we've just had a major earthquake
it was so strong I'm sure a tidal wave
is coming so before he is emailing me
before the tidal wave is hit so i get my
staff and within minutes we are
contacting our network of churches all
down the Thai Coast Sri Lanka Banda Aceh
up into India we're saying take your
relief teams and head for the coast
tidal waves property I already happened
we had teams within minutes headed for
relief same thing happened in Katrina we
had 6,800 churches in our network that
were in the path of Katrina 600 of them
lost their buildings most of them poor
african-american churches and we took up
an offering for Sri Lanka which was 1.6
million dollars for the tsunami and nine
months later took up 1.7 million dollar
offering for the Katrina people and what
we decided to do is care for the
caregivers anybody can buy water in cots
so we said we will pay the salaries of
these people who've lost their own homes
lost their church their synagogue
whoever their their house of worship
they've lost their their friends and
their vol moved off but if we pay their
salary they can help rebuild the city so
we paid the salaries of many of those
pastors almost a year
you